British politics has lost a towering
figure Nigel Lawson best known as
Margaret Thatcher's Chancellor from 1983
to 89.
an architect of the transformative
economic policy that defined the
political landscape during that period
from the decline of heavy industry to
the booming city of London his
resignation delivered a damaging blow to
the Prime Minister a year later she was
forced out of office latterly in his
career he became a central figure in the
brexit movement serving as chair of vote
leave whatever the result of the
referendum the conservative party will
need to come together again and carry on
governing on a whole range of issues he
was also an outspoken climate change
skeptic his death has prompted a wave of
heartfelt tributes from the Prime
Minister who tweeted one of the first
things I did as Chancellor was hang a
picture of Nigel Lawson above my desk
he was a transformational Chancellor and
an inspiration to me and many others
former prime minister Boris Johnson
called him a giant what's the current
Chancellor Jeremy Hunt described him as
a rarity amongst politicians
he began his parliamentary career in
1974. standing down in 1992 to enter the
House of Lords from there he served
until his resignation in December last
year
he leaves behind six children including
his high-profile daughter Nigella Lawson
food writer and TV chef
he also leaves behind a significant
political Legacy a country fundamentally
Changed by his time in office a man who
made a lasting impact Liz Bates Sky News
Westminster